bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros comenzamos suecia a
diferencia de la mayoría de países
cuenta una historia diferente en la
manera de contener la pandemia en su
territorio desde la primera ola el uso
de la mascarilla no ha sido obligatorio
tampoco se optó por confinamiento
ni por el cierre de restaurantes y
aunque la amenaza de contagio se
intensificó sus medidas siguen siendo
menos estrictas que en muchos otros
países pero que tanto le ha funcionado
al país esta flexibilización decía el
fomento de la autodisciplina la
responsabilidad individual el
distanciamiento social y el teletrabajo
generalizado suecia tiene 10 veces más
muertes por el virus que sus vecinos
noruega y finlandia un equipo de
nuestros reporteros viajó a la península
escandinava para entender el
comportamiento del virus y se encontró
con que muchos suecos viajan a dinamarca
y finlandia por temor a contagiarse en
su propio país
esta es la historia
[Música]
hay cierto perfil en mis padres nos
dijeron que estaban un poco enfermos
pero no mucho nada de todos ni fiebre ni
problemas respiratorios
luego cuando no volvimos a tener
noticias suyas durante días le pedimos
al vecino que fuera a ver porque tiene
un doble juego de llaves queríamos saber
lo que ocurría nos devolvió la llamada
para decirnos que había descubierto a mi
madre muerta en el sofá de la sala iii a
mi padre inconsciente en el suelo de la
habitación condujeron rápidamente a mi
padre al hospital dos semanas después
los médicos lo enviaron a casa diciendo
que ya no corría peligro con el codo y
19 y 10 semanas después lo encontraron
muertos
ramón en
emma también contrajo el virus y se está
recuperando difícilmente de las secuelas
de un cómic largo en su casa a 90
kilómetros al norte de estocolmo
recuerdos con sus padres son numerosos
esta es una pared a manera de recuerdo
de la calma esta es mi madre con mis
perros y los hijos los amaba mucho este
es mi padre le encantaba la jardinería
se fueron absolutamente no voy a
esperada mente yo quería que estuvieran
con nosotros de una manera u otra por
mis hijos porque esos abuelos les hacen
mucha falta
estoy convencida de que la estrategia
del gobierno fue que el virus se
propagará no de manera descontrolada
pero lo suficiente como para causarle la
muerte a muchas personas
muchas vidas podrían haber sido salvando
is in that we love me animen y piper
life estructural bin zeid
suecia fue a contracorriente de muchos
países no hubo confinamiento y el
tapabocas fue considerado como
ineficiente para vencer el cob y 19 la
mayoría de los suecos apoyan a las
autoridades y el teletrabajo se
generalizó pero los llamados a la
responsabilidad y el distanciamiento
social no fueron suficientes
suecia está en el promedio europeo pero
cuenta con 10 veces más de muertos por
coronavirus que sus vecinos noruegos y
finlandeses con el invierno la amenaza
creció y tuvieron que cambiar de
estrategia
el gobierno introdujo leyes
excepcionales que limitaron las
reuniones sin cerrar los comercios
anders técnica es el rostro de esta
estrategia sueca tan diferente
hello
recurrimos a medidas voluntarias más que
obligatorias porque ello corresponde al
marco legal nuestro en suecia
contamos con amplio apoyo de la
población que fue disciplinada en la
aplicación de las medidas pero también
contamos con medidas restrictivas como
por ejemplo la limitación de la cantidad
de personas en los restaurantes o la
limitación de horarios para la venta de
alcohol
cuando se estudian los informes de
nuestras regiones que le hacen
seguimiento a los casos vemos que los
contagios no se dieron en los
restaurantes
nuestra convicción basada en evidencia
recolectada es que la estrategia de
mantenerlos abiertos con restricciones
con funciona bastante bien las word web
a 5 horas en barco de estocolmo en medio
del mar báltico se encuentran las islas
finlandesas de avant
un archipiélago de 30.000 habitantes en
el que se instaló sigue esta estudiante
sueca atiende a distancia sus clases por
ahora no le interesa regresar a su país
de origen
sus amigos finlandeses la apoyan
yo aquí soy nueva tú naciste aquí sí y
la gran diferencia es que tú no puedes
regresar a suecia y tu familia y amigos
allá te hace mucha gracia si es cierto
antes de la pandemia y regresado
semanalmente a expresión
y por qué no regresas
debido a la crisis el coronavirus en su
decía la situación es terrible
hay gran propagación de coronavirus y
las medidas adoptadas me parecen
inadecuadas
si alguien es testeado positivo aquí de
inmediato todos los contactos son
puestos en cuarentena pero en suecia los
compactos le dicen solamente que presten
atención si tienen su intención entonces
tengo la impresión de quien quiera que
yo le cruce en suecia podría ser
portavoz del virus en la medida en que
no hay trazabilidad si usted quiere que
su población cuente con buena salud
y entonces creo que el tiempo dirá qué
estrategia es la más eficaz nadie puede
decirlo grave fue diplomático
efe
mezcla la cultura sueca y finlandesa
pero la gestión de la crisis del
coronavirus generó una brecha política
bienvenidos al gobierno de la provincia
autónoma de ala
noo trompos trabajaba para la
organización mundial de la salud antes
de mudarse a esta isla apacible la
epidemiólogo responsable del diagnóstico
está a cargo de aplicar las directivas
de health inc
al principio de la pandemia finlandia
cerró las escuelas y los comercios
suecia eligió esperar sus vecinos no lo
entendieron
hay ciudadanos suecos que por ejemplo
tienen su vehículo registrado en suecia
y cuando vienen aquí la gente se da
cuenta de que son suecos son señalados y
la situación nos incomoda la gente
cuenta hechos similares en todas las
zonas fronterizas suecas con los países
nórdicos se trata de una especie de
estigmatización basada en la
nacionalidad
un puñado de hospitalizaciones
relacionadas con el coronavirus fueron
censadas en la isla
sigrid se siente protegida todos los
días habla con escandinavos para
comparar las estrategias
hay mucho conflicto resentimiento entre
la gente tipo a la época
hay opiniones distintas de muchas
familias y círculos y amigos la gente se
dividió yo he perdido amigos de baile
con frecuencia aplaudida por su modelo
social
suecia recibe malas críticas sobre la
estrategia según siglo
mucha gente confía mucho en su gobierno
y la noción de autoridad
también está la excepción sueca queremos
tanto que las autoridades del país
tengan razón que no cueste hacer los
hechos a los pueblos de los países
nórdicos están golpeados y tristes lo
mejor hubiese sido que todos los países
nórdicos adopten la misma estrategia
para que las fronteras hubiesen podido
permanecer abiertas
nosotros en adelante vivimos gracias al
turismo visitantes que vienen en ferry
el cierre de las fronteras le hacen
mucho daño a nuestra economía
en todas las zonas fronterizas el
desempleo creció
manu ciudad del sur vive como el resto
de suecia sin tapabocas y sin los
visitantes frecuentes
unidad llegó hace pocos meses antes del
inicio de la pandemia la gestión de el
coronavirus nos sorprendió
sexual se hará cuando feliz todo el
mundo podría salir a trabajar no había
nada
entonces los otros países escandinavos
cerraron sus fronteras
fue complicado para nosotros los
franceses besitos
yo perdí mi empleo a suecia entonces no
tenía cómo encontrar otro empleo en otro
lado
finalmente este francés expatriado
encontró un empleo a 30 minutos en tren
en la capital danesa las reglas son
estrictas para evitar la propagación del
virus
vidal debe mostrar un test psr negativo
meisel test en copenhague y me lo envían
directamente a mi casa por ti copias
en dinamarca el test es gratuito a
diferencia de suecia
ahora debo prepararme con antelación
primero mi pasaporte mi número temporal
sueco para poder regresar a malmö claro
ni tapabocas como todo eso mi maleta
luego esta mitad es kobe electrónico en
el teléfono todo lo que llamo dong y que
se montarán
varias veces a la semana nidal se va a
trabajar a un restaurante danés que
vende únicamente platos para llevar
debido al coronavirus
los viajes entre marm y copenhague son
frecuentes y normalmente están llenos de
gente
acabamos de pasar la frontera sueca
llegamos al territorio danés donde el
tapabocas es obligatorio
de lo contrario la multa
las fronteras están cerradas salvo en
caso excepcional
los policías daneses a veces se suben
para verificar las certificaciones
cambio de paisaje radical comparado con
mango
en copenhague los comercios están
cerrados dinamarca vive al ritmo de un
nuevo confinamiento estricto y las
reglas parecen ser respetadas la
estrategia permitió tener una tasa de
mortalidad por coronavirus tres veces
más baja que en suecia al principio de
los colegas de nidal estaban un poco
distantes
los daneses este mismo ahora las cosas
han cambiado un poco porque para ir a
trabajar a copenhague hay que hacerse
antes cada 7 días
entonces ya hay confianza y
para el joven francés la vida es más
complicada en esta escandinavia que
sueña con descubrir
hoy en día sobre vivo para pagarme
alivio en la votación de punk ha
empezado al cielo mi aventura
en toda escandinavia la vida de sus
habitantes cambió debido a la pandemia
del cob y 19 al igual que su
controvertida estrategia anders tecno
divide adulado por numerosos suecos está
en primera línea la situación sanitaria
evolucionó con el paso de los meses y
las recomendaciones también frente a la
amenaza de una tercera ola suecia
considera por primera vez cerrar sus
comercios la tentación de un
confinamiento antes de que sea demasiado
tarde
gracias por acompañarnos una vez más en
esta emisión de reporteros recuerden que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ver esta emisión
y las anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]